for all the talk of how taxing game
development can be in general some games
earn a reputation for being especially
troubled in the eyes of the public
labeled as being in development hell for
taking much longer than a typical Dev
cycle it's not often such games release
in a state anyone would want to
experience if they release at all damn
Buster Studios tosses aside Dead Island
2's uninspiring last decade of Dev hell
like a zombie gnawing for its throat and
delivers an undead RPG that is surely
imperfect but also enjoyable and even
inventive no one's been through this
before Yes again again
this time it happened twice already all
got covered up Dead Island 2 is a first
person action RPG set to the backdrop of
the same Zombie Plague that caused
Mayhem in the original game story it
moves this series away from its
fictional island of Benoit and brings it
to Los Angeles which you may recall is
definitely not an island it's an odd
move given the franchise's name but a
forgivable one once you begin to explore
as the semi-open world of the game's
story and setting proved to be one of
its greatest aspects in my preview of
the game a few weeks ago I was a bit
underwhelmed with the linearity of the
places I had seen up to that point but
my limited hands on time didn't tell the
whole story none of the game's dozen
Plus locations are massive but many of
them are big enough and regardless of
its size each zone is full of secrets
side quests and plenty of reasons to
stray from the main path Dead Island 2
Shooks a true sandbox style open world
in favor of smaller but more authored
locales with far fewer repeating
elements it's ultimately a benefit to
the game as it tends to strike an
engrossing balance between width and
depth the game's World design relies on
indirect routes while exploring the pier
fences will cause you to duck through
the arcade and pass the bumper cars to
get to the other end creating new set
pieces and keeping you zigzagging
through the unpredictable World on the
beach storefronts are often explorable
rewarding you with great weapons cash
for upgrades or other optional Secrets
there are few straight paths through LA
and around every corner you'll find more
monsters and the treasures they Loom
over backtracking is common especially
when tackling the game's three dozen
side missions alongside its two does
main quests your first time through any
Zone you won't be able to see and do
everything and the many locked doors
you'll leave behind make retreading your
steps a rewarding effort as side quests
open up new avenues consistently getting
through the world of hella isn't just
about walking the Venice Beach Boardwalk
or trekking down the lavish Beverly
Hills chiefly it's about bludgeoning
beheading maiming or otherwise
decommissioning the countless zombies
who get in your way Dead Island 2 does
an excellent job of evolving its first
person combat by way of both ample enemy
variety and a deep satisfying combat
system that feels both weighty and
varied I was still discovering new
weapons even after I beat the main story
including some named weapons that
represent the game's best loot available
all right
each weapon be it a firefighter's ax a
wrench a baseball bat or one of the many
others feel different and the crafting
system contains dozens of blueprints
that can customize each weapon several
times over giving them familiar but
still exciting status effects as well as
Buffs to your chosen Slayer of the
game's roster of six Heroes with so much
weapon variety the zombies do well to
match the early distinction between
Walkers Runners and shamblers doesn't
take long to give away to Hulk like
crushes disorienting screamers and much
more for the most part dambuster stays
true to the Mythos of the original game
by reintroducing the same classes of
zombies albeit now with more variety in
their unique immunities like electrified
screamers who can't be killed with
electricity since well that's already
their whole deal
even then the game does introduce some
new types of Undead not previously seen
in the series too adding weight and
variety to the combat is great but it's
not really new to the genre Dead Island
2's secret weapon is its highly detailed
damage model something dambuster can
hang its hat on every single enemy in
the game exists like the world's
grossest onion with each layer able to
be peeled via Katana Mallet or anything
else you'll equip every slash is
accounted for visually its placement
tracks with your exact attack location
smash a zombie with a baton and the
skull will crumble away to reveal the
brain or perhaps their jaw will hang
loose like keys on a lanyard frying them
to a crisp with electricity or melting
away their skin with an in-universe
sludge called caustic X will provide
markedly different results
this makes it so that not only do you
need to consider how and where to
inflict damage upon every single enemy
in the game but every slash gash and
Bash will be accounted for it's unlike
anything I've seen in a zombie game and
I've played dozens of them I've never
really been into goal for Gore's sake
but even I'll admit that's a special
type of flare to punching a hole from
the head of a zombie with homemade
Wolverine claws that you just don't see
in the genre very much regardless of the
medium combining all of the exciting
weapons with the highly varied hordes of
zombies makes each encounter a conscious
effort rarely is it the case where you
can turn your brain off and Bash through
a collection of undeads to get to an
objective they're blocking each fight
takes a concerted thoughtful effort and
to my surprise it stays tough all the
way through all this praise is not
without some caveats however for one
that difficulty can sometimes wade into
feeling unfair enemies spawn quickly and
the game rarely lets you rest in the
game's two or three player co-op this is
usually fine as you have Helping Hands
and it gives the world a sense of
insecurity that a Zombie Plague should
provide but in single player some of
these encounters as well as the
Relentless enemy spawning may leave you
feeling like you're swimming Upstream in
a river of blood and viscera sometimes a
particular enemy will be the focus of
your objective and though the game does
well to Telegraph this it can be tough
to push through the horde to get to the
one whose re-death will actually halt
The Horde from persisting
okay
oh God secondly none of my praise for
the game's melee combat can be applied
to its gun play guns start to crop up in
the game about a third of the way
through the story and though there is
also plenty of variety in these weapons
made Deeper by player-driven
customizations guns are unwieldy and
often feel like a liability oddly they
feel better to use when fired from the
hip rather than aiming down the sights
there's a cumbersome unpredictability
whenever the site is used which creates
a discrepancy between where you were
targeting before and after aiming this
slows down Gunplay as it means
constantly re-lining up shots and no
that should at least mean the shotguns
of the world are fine as they hardly
require aiming they always felt
underpowered the game's best gun the
hunting rifle was my go-to when I felt
like I had to use any Firearms but even
then I just try to line up headshots
from the hip knowing that aiming more
than that would likely just call me to
waste ammo still you can feasibly beat
the game using few to no guns at all and
you may be better off for it exploration
combat and upgrades all shine which is
helpful when the story is so forgettable
though the sequel is written by a
different team than the original Dead
Island 2's writing suffers from problems
that tie them together like a familiar
bouquet of unexplained motivations
grating dialogue and a Bad final act
that speeds past a would-be Charming
level of campiness and crashes into
grown-inducing territory
don't tell me you're on her side
don't let anyone put poison in your hair
ah
not today
I would be haunt pressed to name any
character other than my selected hero
Amy or Sam B who reprises his role from
the first game a fictional actor named
Emma jaunt plays a central part 2 and a
shadowy legion of anti-heroes routinely
pops up to mime narrative Intrigue but
none of it amounts to anything the
spirit of the story is fun in a Grand
Theft Auto sort of way in that it
targets above all others Rich American
socialites as the butt of its jokes
though some of these characters are made
out to be good people the writing often
Revels in sending zombie teeth barreling
for the jugulars of streamers actors and
others deemed to be the vapid wealthy
Elite this is merely the heir of
Storytelling lets the world feel lived
in and it actually makes some of the
many Collectibles enjoyable to read
whenever cut scenes would threaten to
tell a story I found myself groaning
like the undead
we gotta get even for a game in
development for more than a decade it's
a minor miracle for Dead Islands 2 to
come out at all the fact that it's
arrived in such a state that players can
have fun with it for the duration of its
story and Beyond even as that story
itself is an afterthought is a testament
to the team that got it to a once
unlikely Finish Line along with the
lacklist story poor Gunplay and some
balancing issues hurt Dead Islands too
but its deep melee combat systems and
Rich setting make it a better game than
the original which is maybe the most
important thing I can say about it after
everything it's been through
all right